Hey, this is Abraham for Samsung Tomorrow TV and I'm at the Samsung...
Just five more minutes, you're not my mom.
All right, fine!
Hey!
This is the Samsung Mobile Console.
It's designed for the Galaxy Note 3 and it turns your Note 3 into an even better gaming device.
Excuse me.
This works with other devices too, right?
So it does!
So, let me show how this works.
It has a clamp on the top for your devices.
So you can place your Galaxy Note 3 in the clamp.
Press the game button and it brings up the games that it has...
...so you can just pick between those and just go.
So the larger the screen, the better the gaming experience, right?
So Samsung put together something called Smart Dock or the Multimedia Dock.
This hooks up your mobile console through that dock into the TV...
...so the dock and the controller are put together by Bluetooth...
...and the dock feeds HDMI into the TV so you can have it on the big screen.
Samsung is all about integrating technology, and this is just pure awesomeness.
So, Abraham for Samsung Tomorrow TV, I'll see you next time.